some people make the news for the right
reasons but some really don't here are
the top 5 jerks of 2014 number 5 bill
the douchebag mark it's the only
religion that acts like the Mafia that
will fucking kill you that you say the
wrong thing that I draw the wrong
picture or write the wrong book
seriously bill more races in the bigotry
this time against Muslims no wonder the
students at UC Berkeley try to stop your
graduation speech number for uber what a
year for these guys pairing riders with
hot chick drivers and France tracking
users walks of shame or rides of glory
there bro CEO even threatened to spend 1
million dollars to dig up dirt on
journalists and they still managed to
trump it all by announcing surge pricing
when a bunch of people were taken
hostage at a sydney cafe number 3 the
Eric garner grand jury because if video
evidence of an illegal chokehold and a
medical examiner's report that screams
homicide aren't enough to indict a cop
who killed an unarmed man then what is
number two the CIA so you torture people
in medieval ways you lie about it
repeatedly and when you're exposed you
refuse to apologize also thanks for
giving dick cheney another opportunity
to be a dick I'd do it again in a minute
number one Isis honestly I don't know
where to start with these the biggest
jerks are 2014 are also the most
dangerous indiscriminate killing of
civilians suicide bombings ethnic
cleansing public the headaches and they
say it's all in the name of religion
that's all sorts of stuff so those are
our biggest jerks of 2014 who was on
your list
you